we make way for Jessica Mendoza ESPN
Sunday Night Baseball analyst she's
appearing on get up with mike Greenberg
this week throughout the World Series
and Jessica joins us Jessica good
morning how are you
dan I'm doing awesome to be honest I
mean I'm rolling on like three hours of
sleep that's how it works play games and
early-morning hours but last night was a
game and I've been waiting for what we
got in Game six this entire series was
that good for baseball last night oh it
was needed I mean we've seen like
all-time low ratings for the first four
games and just really the games being
over early on even even if you felt like
there could be a comeback there wasn't
they just haven't been the excitement
that really we've seen from baseball
throughout the season especially
representing the American League in the
National League pitching matchups that
we hyped up and talked so much about so
I guess they see what we what we saw
last night and honestly even have some
controversy which I think always seems
to help kind of trigger II was an on
baseball fan to kind of dive into the
sport alright the controversy in the
seventh inning with Trey Turner what did
you see I thought you know a first of
all a rule that that is completely vague
and it bothers me so much that it's left
up to the discretion of the umpires in a
situation to me that it's ridiculous
like I've watched that play over and
over again if you can go back to trade
Turner's first single which was another
swinging bunt but Alex Bergman had a
throw off this run but look at the same
path that Turner took the difference was
is Bregman throw was right on the money
so Brad peacock doesn't throw the ball
out Trey Turner in that situation do
they call him out
heck no yeah and that's where the rule
needs to change so I don't like it
totally blame the umpires I blame the
rule because the rule allowed
technically by the standard the Trey
Turner was supposed to be in foul
territory in that Lane so let's be real
you're going point A to point B the
right-handed batter from being in fair
territory to territory
why would you ever run in that lane I go
fired up yeah I'm there with you I just
I would have had a no call on this
because the throw is what created the
controversy even if if Turner is running
in foul territory I still think he's
going to come in contact with girls
glove and and and so I I don't know I I
know that they want to call it by the
letter of the rule like the Tuck rule
with Tom Brady you know we get caught up
in all of this but you know to me this
shouldn't have been called I think it
was a bad throw and therefore you
created a controversy that wasn't there
it's like if you briefly you know get a
shooter in basketball like by the tip of
your fingernail it happens to touch
their skin and you call it a belt I mean
yes by the rule is he's supposed to
completely be into that lane but when
you actually look at the sport itself
like contact happens in basketball guys
are going to run towards the bag from
the point of where they go just to get
there as fast as they possibly can and
that's what happens when you have a bag
in fair territory
you've got the box in fair territory and
then you're expecting runners to run in
foul territory the rule itself and
unfortunately thank goodness by the way
that did not enter because there was a
moment dance you know you're watching
that game live and it felt like eternity
when the headsets were on and Davy's
losing his mind and Trey Turner's
yelling out the next like five years but
you know what was lost in all of this is
Stephen Strasburg was a man again oh and
when you think about okay the attention
that has gone to this series the four
pitchers okay so it's Gerrit Cole Justin
Verlander Max Scherzer and then forth as
far as attention has been Stephen
Strasburg
and yet he has been number one for me he
sealed the deal for that last night in
the way that she threw especially in
that fifth inning and this is a story
I've it you know you think about him
coming up and how much he was put on the
pedestal of being literally like almost
Bryce Harper esque
of the pitching world not being able to
pitch in 2012 getting shut down
controversy of that this story has been
really impressive and I look at that
fifth inning with Jose Altuve up to bat
I felt like to me Dan that was the
theory right there in one at-bat Stephen
Strasburg giving him a changeup and then
back-to-back curveballs to get in my
opinion the toughest hitter to swing in
this yeah the swing and miss yeah great
and and that that was the best pitching
I've ever seen him do in one a bat I
agree with you because l2v always puts
the ball in play and then you strike him
out and that that was a huge huge moment
you have the two home runs Bregman and
Soto and we're carrying the bat now down
to first base here where do you stand on
this I love it I love it I the only
thing I don't love is that Alex Bregman
felt forced to apologize after the game
and that's the criticism that he got in
doing that anyone knows that Alex
Bregman that is his I mean because I
want it flashing up the forefingers
after a home run previously because he's
saying you should have walked me I mean
this is a guy that does not lack
confidence and you know what that's who
he is
bu and that's him and I I think maybe
the handoffs needs a little bit of work
he wouldn't have been on a relay team
with the baton there Jessica oh no but
you know one photo after the game saying
I thought it was cool I wanted to do it
soon like this is where we're at with
players right now and this is who they
are and I absolutely love it because of
its landing themselves in you know at
the end there's some kid I've got two
boys at home some young girls some young
boy that's watching that going okay this
is a sport I can be myself it and I
think that hasn't always been the case
in baseball yeah I think you're in the
minority but I'm with you in the
minority I I think baseball doesn't
celebrate baseball as much as all the
other sports you know football finally
came back around and said you know you
guys want to have a little bit of fun in
the end zone and with your cleats
basketball it's an individual sport
baseball sort of lost out on that and
maybe they're they're trying to make up
for lost time I'll leave you with this
jessica is as sure's are good to go you
know I think if anyone can battle
through anything I mean I just have this
image right down of him pitching
with a black eye
right and then he comes to Mexico can't
even see half of his eye and he finds a
way to battle through that game and I
remember we had them that like the next
week and I remember talking to team and
they just rallied around him
I don't think Scherzer is gonna have his
best stuff I don't even know how long
he's going to be able to go but there's
something about him throwing in this
game you couldn't have scripted it any
better this team would not have choose
chosen to not have him in Game five but
it's almost like this is what was
supposed to be right you want Scherzer
in seven a series of going Game seven
against that great well I think he's a
badass I love Scherzer he's one of the
him and Cole you know those are the two
guys I would just pay to watch them
pitch I just love that they get the ball
and they throw it there's no nonsense
there they're bringing it right at you
and he's out there warming up just like
I mean just pacing to like put me in
I'll pitch tonight I'll pitch tomorrow
if that ain't my Scherzer I don't know
what is yes yes fun to watch
yeah hey I hope you're doing well and
thanks for joining us Jessica Jessica
Mendoza working for the mothership ESPN
Sunday Night Baseball and appearing on
get up with mike Greenberg throughout
the World Series for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]